there's a choice we have to make as
people as individuals so if you want to
be great at something you have to make
the inherent sacrifices that come along
with that family time hanging out with
your friends said the age 18 I knew that
I was not going to be stopped this was
my life we all can be masters at our
craft but you have to make sacrifices
that come along with making a decision
on January 26 Kobe Bryant and his
daughter were among nine people who were
killed in a helicopter crash in
Calabasas California he dominated in
basketball he was dominating in business
and as a tribute to him my team and I
pulled together a mix of some of the
best lessons you can learn from him be
inspired by him and remember him I hope
you enjoy lesson number one outwork
everyone
I've been with you for a long way the
one moment that stands out out of we've
done I don't know how many done we've
done no play eight hundred events the
one time was 4:00 a.m. we went out to
practice at 4:00 a.m. and that was your
idea to do it well then you know all
these Nike people are like no no no no
let's not let's not do that
and then you're like let's do it at 4:00
a.m. so you got security you got brand
marketing in sports marketing go no no
no no no no that's not good you're like
let's do it because that's your
sustenance I mean to me it just makes
complete sense not to us see we all
right what you usually I'm sleeping at
4:00 a.m. you're you're working out so I
lied about that okay so if if your job
is to try to be the best basketball
player you can be okay to do that you
have to practice you have to train right
you want to train as much as you can as
often as you can
so if you get up at 10:00 in the morning
train at 11:00 12:00 say 12:00 train at
12:00 train for two hours 12:00 to 2:00
you have to let your body recover so you
eat recover whatever you get back out
you train start training again at 6:00
train from 6:00 to 8:00 right and now
you go home and shower you eat dinner
you go to bed you wake up do it again
right those are two sessions all right
now imagine you wake up at 3:00 you
train at 4:00 you go 4 to 6 come home
breakfast relax so so now you're back at
it again
9211 relax and now it's on your back at
it again to the four and have your back
at it again you know seven to nine look
how much more training I have done by
simply starting at four all right so now
you do that and as the years go on the
separation that you have with through
competitors and your peers just grows
larger and larger and larger and larger
and larger and by year five or six
doesn't matter what kind of work they're
doing a summer they're never going to
catch up because they're five years
behind so it makes sense to get up and
start your day early because you can get
more working is that genetic or is that
something you you engrained and trained
yourself no it was just you that for me
it was it was just common sense like I
can okay if I start earlier I can train
more hours and I know the other guys
aren't doing it because I know what
their training schedule is right so I
know if I do this consistently over time
it's the gaps just gonna widen and why
no why no why no why and they won't be
able to get that back mm-hmm
so it's me it was just common sense I'm
like thinking how can I get an advantage
oh start earlier yeah let's do that how
do you develop that or where do you what
do you learn that from well I I think
it's just no it's just a matter of
what's important to you mhm
what's important to you for whatever
reason you know I felt like I didn't
feel good about myself if I wasn't doing
everything I could to be the best
version of myself if I felt like I left
anything on a table it would eat away at
me I wouldn't be able to look myself in
the mirror right so the reason why I can
retire now and be completely comfortable
about it because I know that I've done
everything I could to be the best
basketball player I could be and so
that's where it comes from for me you
can't leave any stone unturned
I think the best way to prove your value
is to work is to learn is to absorb to
be a sponge you always want to outwork
your potential as hard as you believe
you can work you can work harder than
that and that's what I try to do when I
first came and lead but you know
basketball is such a direct competition
sport and me coming in at 17
when like my teammates would say you
know I get hit with an elbow right shack
with you threw an elbow in practice and
like you know Nick Van Exel will come up
and say are you okay but how are you
okay
hell's wrong with you you know it's so
like I always had that extra chip on my
shoulder so like every day I practice
for me was really trying to annihilate
everybody that was that I was playing
against cuz I wanted to prove you don't
need to babysit me like I'm fine
you know and and so as always that
competitive nature the work ethic and
curiosity because I asked a lot of
questions you know playing what Byron
Scott I asked him a lot of questions
Eddie Jones who was great at chasing
guards off the screens and I didn't
understand how to do that I would sit
with him before practice after practice
magic James Worthy Kurt Rambis Kareem
Abdul all the Laker grades I would
always sit down and just asking
questions about certain games that I've
studied growing up what actually
happened there what did you feel that
why you know bird tough to defend why
cuz you look slow to me I'm up like I'm
missing something so like tell me what
I'm missing you know what I mean and so
I would always ask questions and try to
learn as much as I could that's the
number to be a long term thinker I had a
summer where I played basketball when I
was like 10 or 11 years old and a very
prominent some really good Philadelphia
called the Sonny he'll be there my
father played my uncle played never like
all-time great stuff and Wilt
Chamberlain played in league you know
another Pearl Monroe playing weed and
yeah come playing and I don't score one
point the entire summer
really not one how old were you 11 10 11
and you're playing against other 10 11
year-old start and you didn't score once
not one were you in the game I was in
again how'd you not score because that
was terrible really yeah that happened
11 years old you were that awful I mean
I you know and I had these big knee pads
on because I'm
relatively fast I have socks all the way
up here and I had like the pod top
Phoebe likes skinny as hell and I scored
not a free-throw not a nothing not a
lucky shot not a breakaway layup zero
points is that when you think the
mentality of hard work started to come
in for you at that age when you failed
so miserably I guess that's somewhere I
think that's when the idea of
understanding a long-term view became
important because I wasn't going to
catch these kids in a week I wasn't
gonna catch him in a year right so
that's when I sat down and said okay
this is gonna take some father all right
we'd all want to work on first
all right shooting all right let's knock
this out let's focus on this half a year
six months do nothing but shoot all
right after that
all right creating your own shot and
then you focus so you start I started
creating a menu of things when I came
back the next summer I was a little bit
better right
men you'd be like I've got my jump shot
from 15 I've got ya I got my job from 15
I got my three-point shot like just open
shots not miss open shots right and be
able to shoot it with speed because
those kids are so much more athletic
yeah and then the next time I came back
a little better the summer came back a
little bit I scored yeah it wasn't much
but I scored 12 13 12 13 then 14 came
around back half of 13 14 years old and
then I was just killing everyone and it
happened in two years and I wasn't
expecting happened in two years but it
did because what I had to do was work on
the basics and the fundamentals while
they relied on an athletics ISM and
their natural ability and because I
stick to the fundamentals it just caught
up to him and then my body you know my
knees stopped hurting I grew into my
frame and and then your athleticism once
you have the fundamentals actly the hard
work the mindset and you tack on the 11
did it was game Wow
so from 13 you're good average still
that was good that was good about about
like the end of my 30 like right when I
was turning 14 I became best clear in
the state at 14 or 14 so I'm from 12 to
14 you went from scoring zero to being
the best in the state of all ages yep
lesson number three have a strong
purpose trivial things weren't gonna
pull my attention it had to be sayings
weren't gonna pull my attention had to
be things that
were I had a purpose I wanted to be one
of the best basketball players to ever
play and anything else that was outside
of that lane I didn't have time for at
what age did that goal become crystal
clear diamond I made that deal with
myself at 13 years old at 13 years 13
years old I made clear about it crystal
clear and what did inspiration come from
the love of the game the love of the
game the challenge like I would watch
magic play I'd watch Michael play and I
would see them do these unbelievable
things and I say you know can I get to
that level
oh no but let's find out lesson number
four get better every single day my
philosophy was a very simple one I am
and this is where I think film plays a
big part of my life you know Rudy was
one of my favorite films growing up
after watching that film I come to
understand if I could work that hard
every day with the being blessed with
the physical tools that I have with my
career being and I made a promise to
myself from that day that I was going to
work that hard every single day so that
when I do retire I have no regrets and
that was the most important thing for me
to leave no stone unturned get better
every single day and if I live that way
then over time you know I'd have
something that was beautiful but that
was my philosophy it seems like a pretty
simple one but you know if you lived
your life to just get better every
single day and do that for 20 years I
mean what do you have lesson number five
follow your passion follow your passion
first first first first first first and
when I retired from the game yeah I said
they're asking kind of all the wrong
questions
and what's the biggest industry I can
get into and it's all the wrong stuff
and you got to sit there and ask
yourself okay what am I truly passionate
about what do I enjoy doing and when you
feel that way honestly I mean you feel
like you have never worked a day in your
life it's the most fun thing in the
world you get up in the morning excited
about what you're doing and you got to
be really honest with yourself about it
if you wake up in the morning and you're
dreading going to work dude do something
else do something else and those are
hard decisions to make but when you make
those decisions it's a very liberating
experience and you'll find out that the
rewards will come lesson number six
commit fully you said I read a quote
that you said you love business as much
as basketball there's no way that's true
it's a hundred percent review there's no
way you look I mean basketball was your
life you your passion everything you
you're telling me you love doing
business as much if you could you know
basically snap a finger and be twenty
five-year-old Kobe or the Kobe today you
wouldn't go back and keep playing
basketball no because I've already done
it see here's the thing when I was
playing and you know teammates would say
oh Kobe's not out on the road what is he
doing you see me on the plane he's
reading what is he reading he's writing
what is he writing I'm practicing I'm
writing I'm practicing I'm understanding
how to tell stories I'm reading Joseph
Campbell and how to create arts
compelling arts and plots I'm reading
that stuff so this is going back 15
years right so I don't just retire right
dear basketball and lucky in the winning
an Oscar you don't say yeah stuff comes
from hard work and from studying for 15
years how to write and how to organize
structure right and you can't do that
without having a serious love or
commitment to the craft lesson number
seven focus on one thing do you think
one of the edge you had over everybody
else was the biggest percentage of your
focus was on one thing do you see it
that way like that was my edge over
everybody else I do at the time I didn't
really understand that right so you know
basketball for me was the most important
thing so everything I saw whether it was
TV shows whether it was books I read
people I talked to everything was done
to try to learn how to become a better
basketball player everything everything
and so when you have that point of view
then literally the world becomes your
library to help you to become better at
your craft lesson number eight be the
best you can be
I was wondering if you've had to tone
down your come
give nests in your approach in the new
work environment oh yeah yeah more than
a little bit ya know it well bat like I
said basketball it's different because
it's such a direct competition what we
do now there isn't because the
competitiveness that I bring to work
everyday is really helping people in a
sense be competitive with themselves
right if you're if you're animating
something or or you're writing a
screenplay or you're composing a piece
of music is that the best you could do
don't ask me don't say do you approve
don't ask me I'm not the musician I'm
not the composer you know right so the
competitiveness is more from an
individual perspective are you is this
the best you can do and if the answer is
yes then off we go lesson number nine
study success kind of take us behind
kind of the current with Michael was
there ever a moment that you guys spoke
but you felt like it energizing you
learned from him yeah it was it was
crazy man cuz my favorite player was
magic growing up mhm
and then I quickly realized my father
stole all my height and I was gonna be a
69 point guard so I did you know so look
at this young guy coming up and the
thing that I marveled at wasn't the fact
that he was getting to the rim and doing
these fancy stuff it was like how is he
getting to the rim how is he doing it
right you look at the footwork look at
the fundamentals they got the spacing
the pacing right and all those little
things the angles and that's what
becomes fascinating it's like oh okay
how do I get there
alright so I started studying all those
basics and then when I came to lead the
first time I played against home um I
won his respect because it was like this
kids not scared of me at all mm-hmm
right and he saw a kindred spirit from
that standpoint and that started a
relationship and it became something
where it was like no text them anytime
hits me right back questions hits me
right back and when talking all the time
lesson number 10 learn from failures we
talk about this often and we always talk
about the fact that you can learn a lot
more from the failures and you can from
the successes and you have to figure out
where those landmines are
and then how to best avoid those or put
or help entrepreneurs and ourselves
included figure out the clues of where
those landmines are not that you're
going to avoid all of them but it's also
when you do step on one figure it out
okay how do you recuperate how do you
balance back and you'll pick yourself up
lesson number eleven
protect your dreams dreams is a they
should be pure I think a lot of times
we're born into this world we actually
wind up going backwards and it seems
like the more we mature the more
responsible our dreams become and the
more governors we put on ourselves and
our ability to dream and to reimagine
and it's always a fight for his parents
and for you guys to make sure that your
dreams always stay pure and so it's not
a matter of pushing beyond the
limitations of expectations it's really
a matter of protecting your dreams
protecting your imagination that's
really the key and when you do that then
the world just seems limitless lesson
number 12 love the game the passion came
from the love for the game you know I
loved everything about it like the smell
of the ball you love the smell of the
ball this ball you know the smell of
like brand-new sneakers and like the
sound the ball mace when it hits the
ground sneakers in the gym yeah the ball
going through the net like all those
things I love and so the passion comes
from that because once you have that
love you just want to be a part of this
thing all the time
is there one moment where you can say it
defined your passion for basketball is
our story or moment when you said yeah
that wasn't it that was it that was like
when I felt really passionate no it
doesn't never leave never leaves like
that you know the game was just a part
of me so it never leaves even now that
I'm retired you know everything I've
learned from the game of basketball
carried it over into life mm-hmm you
know like basketballs helped me be a
better person a better friend a better
house other well because there's life
lessons that are within the game
communications like unselfishness my
attention to detail and empathy and
compassion like all those things are in
the game and as an athlete if we are
aware of those things it helps us become
better human human beings mm-hmm and you
can apply that toward your post post
basketball game retirement into your
business world showing true ventures
sure I mean you can play you know I was
applying that even while I was playing
just in life outside of the game and
even more so now you know I'm building a
business and all these things you know
kind of culture you when I have and all
those things are or directly learn from
the game of basketball to me lesson
number 13 worked the hardest I read a
story that you used to play guys to a
hundred you do be like you have to stay
in this gym and play me to a hundred and
I mean what was the biggest margin of
victory you'd ever went well you in high
school used to spy guys 99 no kidding
but you know listen these practices
practices are meant to be competitive
they're meant to be competitive if your
practices aren't more competitive than
the games themselves you're doing the
wrong thing mm-hmm
and most of these teams and coaches have
gotten into a mindset of resting players
oh it's too much you know we're not
gonna practice light daylight daylight
they feel never gave us a light day
there's no days off you show up and you
work in practice
yeah and practices are going to be worse
it ought to be more physical there's
gonna be more trash-talking now I'm
gonna let you know right yeah yeah
you're gonna show up today I'm gonna let
you know yeah it's gonna be embarrassing
you're gonna hate it
but when Game seven rolls around the NBA
Finals you will be prepared lesson
number fourteen push through the pain it
was kind of
the perfect series playing the Celtics
then being this annoyed and then having
five I mean we joke about that a lot but
the most important thing was beatin
Celtics because of everything they've
meant to this organization
it was a tough series for me most people
know this but I had a bone spur mic and
a couple games in Boston had to leave
the game go back in the locker room and
get it injected because I could barely
walk and I had a broken finger I was
playing with had to cast my right thing
and then I was having to deal with
Garnett Pierce Ray Allen Rondo Rashi
watt I mean all these guys and having to
figure out how to get through that
series and so it was a big relief to win
first and foremost was relief to win and
get out of that series a lot if I lost
to the Celtics manag I've been miserable
unless the number 15 the last one before
a very special bonus lesson is thrive on
being an outsider and I've always had
someone best performances
[Music]
[Applause]
fans
actually we love it Shriver
they don't understand who I am
not only am i comfortable being an
outsider that has become a source of
motivation so when I go to these places
and you
now we have two special bonus clips from
Kobe that I think you're gonna enjoy and
normally here I would ask you the
three-point landing questions but
instead I think to honors memory I'd
love to know what is your either one
greatest memory of Kobe or two what is
the single lesson that you've learned
the most from him that his legacy will
live on through you let me know down the
comments below 96 to 99 was the first
rating point I don't know about well
maybe a little bit for you but for me
being one of the best babes in the
league and having that title of not
winning one I remember one day reading
it reading it and the paper
oceaxe average in 20 or 30 of doing this
and the great Kareem abdul-jabbar said
well he didn't win then he had parent so
is he great and I just kinda I just kind
of dare know why I wanted it you know I
understood it was a necessity to have to
win one there was a lot of pressure and
I think there's a lot of frustration
because you kept seeing this kid and
everybody kept saying can be patient
with this kid be patient with this kid
you're saying listen I don't have
patience I have to win now and this kid
needs to develop now I think I could
remember the first time we had our first
fight and you look this L kid is crazy
at this yeah we're sick we I was we're
playing a pickup games or a lockout
season Southwest college playing a
pickup game we're on opposite teams run
and trash talking yes and you kept
saying yeah take that low take that
little I'm looking around oh yes right
ain't gonna be too many more those low
then would you say what what you gonna
do about it what you gonna do about it
and then ask the next thing I knew I saw
a big hand coming this way and I
remember going this way I remember
throwing some lollipop olden Polynice
game and then they all just kind of
broke his part broke ass out I'm looking
at this and I'm saying right he wants to
stay he's it's it affects him I mean
he's it consumes him and then from that
moment on I knew we spoke the same
language don't matter if we had
disagreements and the other our drive to
win like we have to
when there's there's no other option
we're going to figure this out we won't
get this guy and you did it
[Applause]
Kobe Bryant now I think it's gonna be
retiring yeah I remember season one you
said who is this candy his 20th season
all have various careers in basketball I
will not allow him to be what you want
was any longer no one understand what it
takes to be great the force that drives
you to do what others don't
the sacrifices made all with one purpose
in mind push yourself to become better
the extra seconds minutes hours of work
put into perfecting one's game lifting
yourself above the rest to make sure
your name will forever be synonymous
with one word greatness what does it
take to be great work at the combination
drive takes ability it takes the design
moves on muscle again turns it I think
it takes years of players relying on you
to take the big shot make the great play
you'll do the things that bring success
to the team that's that's what it's all
about is getting out and measure
yourself against others and I think that
when you have an attitude like that
that's what I think that's part of
greatness the first time met Kobe Kobe
was arrested out of high school he's out
here before work up and I've never seen
anyone work out as hard
this is Kobe I've never seen anybody
that prepared he was 17 years old and
was ready to play Andrea basketball
that's that's pretty amazing I think
Jerry West was the one who said this he
said I want this kid because this kid
had more talent
plan for me right now and he had a great
team
just kidding would never take a night
off even if it wasn't calling well it
was always going to be trying to slay
the dragon if you don't have that type
of work after you don't get to enjoy the
benefits
[Applause]
if you want more Kobe Bryant check out
the top 50 rules video I made on him
it's awesome the link is right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there any chances cuz the ship sink and
all of a sudden I'm gonna jump off a
swim to another [ __ ] like that you don't
do that alright you can win
championships in front of everybody